hi I'm Marco I'm a multimedia software
engineer on the Android project and I'd
like to show you my favorite feature of
the music player so here I am listening
to some music in the music player and
one of the things I can do is click on
the artist named Anna little pop-up
comes up i select amazon mp3 and now
it's searching the amazon mp3 store for
albums by this artist and here's the
whole list of things that i can buy
another thing i can do is long press on
the song name and again i'll do an
amazon mp3 search it only finds one
album but if I go over to songs you can
see a whole list of songs remixes
karaoke mixes tribute groups etc another
thing i can do is search for Radiohead
on google and from there i can go to the
official Radiohead website read the
wikipedia entry see their myspace page
etc so let's pick a more recent song now
i happen to know that this song has a
really cool video so I long press on the
title and I do a youtube search and here
it is the first one music stops playing
it's loading the video and now i'm
watching the music video of the song
that I was just listening to